[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
40 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
I'm back.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, welcome back.
MARK MANDEL: It was a short
hiatus, I was very sad.
I was sad to be gone,
but I'm glad to be back.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
No, it was good.
I got a different
Australian, you know.
I could not even tell
the difference, really.
So yeah, don't
worry, don't worry.
You can leave again.
That's fine.
MARK MANDEL: Change is as
good as the holiday, I guess.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
we have many Australians
to replace you, so it's fine.
MARK MANDEL: Good to know
that I'm loved and enjoyed.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, no, no, I'm
very, very happy you're back.
So today, we're going to have
an interview with someone that
works for Rodeo FX.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
really cool company
that does some
really cool stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is a
pretty amazing company.
I've seen a couple videos
of their demos and basically
they do--
MARK MANDEL: Visual effects.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --visual
effects, special effects,
for some people
that you might have
heard about like, I don't
know, "Game of Thrones,"
maybe you've heard about it.
MARK MANDEL:"Deadpool."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, you
know, like it is pretty amazing.
And there's a couple of videos.
We'll put the links on
the show notes as usual.
And this time I really
recommend you to go
check them out because they are
pretty amazing, to be honest.
MARK MANDEL: They're awesome.
They're awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
after that, we'll
end up, as usual, with
a question of the week.
And the question of the week
today is about-- it's something
that you actually came up with.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, well,
I can't take credit.
It was from the Slack community.
We were talking
about it on there,
talking about compute
engine instances,
how to create an instance group
from an already existing Google
Compute Engine virtual machine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That is actually something
I've done before.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is fun.
MARK MANDEL: I've done it before
because I helped someone do it,
so it was a good time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So yeah, we'll talk about that
at the end of the episode.
And now we are going to
talk about the cool thing
of the week.
Actually, it starts
to be like, as usual,
it is not one cool thing of
the week but a bunch of them.
MARK MANDEL: There are
too many cool things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
there's too many cool things.
We need more episodes.
Maybe we should do
these episodes daily.
MARK MANDEL: Don't--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No.
MARK MANDEL: No, no, no.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No,
I think we're fine.
So yeah, we have
three products that
are now generally available.
So they're out of beta,
and you can now use them
with SLAs and all that stuff.
So we have Cloud SQL, Cloud
Bigtable, and Cloud Datastore,
so three different
ways of storing data,
which is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so just to be clear
as well, so that's Cloud
SQL the second generation?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Which has way
more power than the first one,
hugely, hugely cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is incredibly fast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
incredibly, incredibly fast.
And Cloud Datastore
which, I mean,
that's been around for
a while, but is now
generally available
to everything outside
of App Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I think it's
the REST API that is--
because if you were using it
from App Engine, it
was already generally
available from a long time ago.
But now if you're using
it from outside of it,
the API itself is now
generally available, too.
MARK MANDEL: Which is cool.
And Bigtable is just--
well, that's Bigtable.
It's always been really great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Bigtable is amazing.
It is really big.
MARK MANDEL: Really big.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And on the other
side, there's also
a bunch of different things.
And we're going to link to
this, but there's one more thing
that I wanted to mention
because I was actually
really impressed, which is
Google Cloud Storage Nearline.
It is much faster than before.
MARK MANDEL: So quick overview,
Google Cloud Storage Nearline,
where you want to
archive long-time data,
probably not going to
touch it very often.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
mostly logs, backups,
and stuff like that that you
don't really care about them
until you care about them.
And then at that date,
you will get like--
MARK MANDEL: You really care.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --oh,
yeah, I want the backup
from like a year ago.
You want it to be there, really.
So yeah, like I think
the technical name is
infrequently accessed data.
MARK MANDEL: Oooh!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And normally--
there's competitors
that propose things like this,
and it takes a couple hours
to retrieve that data.
From the beginning,
Google proposed
a solution that was like a
couple of minutes instead.
Then we went down to seconds.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a bit better.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
now it is as fast
as a normal Cloud storage.
MARK MANDEL: That
seems just right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
which is pretty amazing
because it's really fast.
I could say, it's probably
around like a couple hundred
milliseconds, so yeah.
MARK MANDEL: As soon as you want
that data is as soon as you're
getting that data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that data is there.
So that is pretty amazing.
And I was so impressed that I
decided to talk about it today,
but there's many other things.
So go check it out.
We have a link to
an announcement.
We had a bunch of new things
that happened this week.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Awesome.
Well, why don't we go
have a chat with Alan
and hear all about
visual effects
in Google Cloud Platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's go with that.
MARK MANDEL: We are joined
today by a gentleman named
Alan Fregtman from Rodeo FX.
How you doing today, Alan?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Hello.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much
for joining us on the podcast.
Do you want to tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you do at Rodeo FX?
ALAN FREGTMAN: So
my name's Alan.
I'm a pipeline
developer at Rodeo FX.
The company has been
around for about 10 years,
and I've been there for four.
And it's grown a lot
since I've been there.
I initially started
as what's known
as a rigger, which
is just the guy who
articulates the characters
or vehicles or such.
And slowly, in the
last couple of years,
I've been doing more
of a developer role,
doing more coding,
mostly Python.
And it's really exciting.
The studio has grown
from like 50 people
to like 300 and something
in a couple of years.
And it's crazy.
MARK MANDEL: So I can
get a bit of an inkling
from the name of the company,
but what exactly does it do?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah, so we
do visual effects for film
and high-end TV series.
We've done some work for
the last three seasons
of "Game of Thrones" and
the occasional commercial
but mostly film.
We did some work on
the last "Star Trek,"
some work on "Deadpool,"
"Birdman," the last "Tarzan,"
"Fantastic Beasts," which
is about to come out soon,
lots of creatures in that
one, really exciting,
and some old stuff, like
"Pacific Rim" and "Edge
of Tomorrow."
MARK MANDEL: Old stuff.
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah,
MARK MANDEL: That
is pretty awesome.
ALAN FREGTMAN: Well, it
seems old in my timeline.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No,
those are awesome.
So when you described
yourself, you
used the term
"pipeline developer"?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
What is that exactly?
ALAN FREGTMAN: So a
pipeline, in my industry,
it's basically the sort of
flow of data from one specialty
to another, so to speak.
So there's a lot of
specialties in visual effects.
It's really hard to
be a one-man shop.
You really got to
specialize, and it
goes through like modeling,
texturing, shading, rigging,
animation, lighting and layout,
and eventually compositing.
And to get everything
to be versioned
and to flow and to
import and export
and all the statuses of
everything and everything
to be up-to-date and correct
and valid and follow convention,
there's this term
of the pipeline,
which is basically sort of
the conglomeration of tools.
It's kind of like, if the tools
were neurons in the brain,
that the mind would
be the pipeline.
It's sort of like the abstract,
all-encompassing concept.
And a pipeline
developer basically
works towards making the flow
of the information smooth.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So could you tell us a little
bit about what kind of tools
or what kind of products you
use to make these happen?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Specifically
in Google or in general?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, in general,
like what kind of tools?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, what
does the process look like?
Like if somebody comes to
you, and they're like, hey,
we want this scene
shot in a movie.
How does that look?
ALAN FREGTMAN: So
initially, there's
a bidding process where
studios say how much they will
cost to do a particular shot.
Then it's up to the
client to decide
who to give what to
based on their reputation
and their funding, I suppose.
Once we get a shot
and it's confirmed,
we usually receive the plates.
Those have to be-- they
have to go through what's
known as match moving,
which is where some very
careful people track
the motion of the camera
with some specialized software.
That is not entirely
automatic, unfortunately,
and there's a lot of manual
work to get that going.
And once we have
the camera, then we
can start creating
creatures and vehicles
and whatever kind of
replacement or enhancement
that the shot requires.
And those have to go through
all the various stages,
initially with modeling,
obviously concept art.
If there's no concept,
there's nothing to model.
But initially
modeling, then it needs
to be textured at some point.
That can usually go in parallel.
And eventually, that goes
into the hands of riggers,
which is what I used to be.
And those guys, they
articulate and add
controls for the animators to
use to bring stuff to life,
be it a creature, or a prop, or
an awesome robot, or whatever.
And then at the
same time, there's
also occasional enhancements
by-- well, I say occasional.
It's not really.
There's a lot of enhancements
of simulations that happen.
Either water
splashes, explosions,
rocks falling,
all kinds of stuff
that the effects department
does in parallel, while everyone
else is trying to
do the creatures,
the vehicles, or props.
And then eventually,
it all comes together
with the help of the
lighters and the render farm,
or hybrid render farm,
part Cloud, part local.
And it goes into the hands
of the compositors, who
then composite the
final layers together
and make the beautiful,
consistent look
throughout the whole thing.
And then that gets
delivered to the client,
and they add music
and do the edit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
So out of my
experience, any-- I've
done some rendering
of videos, and there's
two problems with that.
It takes forever, and you
end up with huge files.
How do you make it happen?
I'm imagining that
to make a dragon look
real, that's a lot of gigabytes
and a lot of processing.
How do you make these
actually happen?
ALAN FREGTMAN:
Yeah, well, we have
a lot of storage on premise.
We have a mix of
different filers
we have acquired
through the years,
and it's all presented
through a caching appliance
that we have as one common
place for the mounts.
And it's many
hundreds of terabytes.
It's really intense.
And some of the stuff
that we do in the pipeline
to try to minimize
the duplication
is to do symlinks when stuff
gets versioned but doesn't
really change.
For example, when the textures
get versioned again and only
like one bit of somewhere
on the thing changed,
then we try to
symlink so we don't
have to copy so much data.
And we try to keep it light.
Obviously, not always the
case, but we do what we can.
And, of course, we use the Cloud
to be able to render really
massive, massive things.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
you're saying-- OK,
you mentioned that you've got a
lot of storage and CPU on prem.
So where does the Cloud-- where
does Google Cloud Platform
come in?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah, so we
do a lot of different movies
at the same time, a lot of
different shows, we call them.
And it could be anything from
like four to a dozen shows
in different stages
of production.
And from time to time, usually
at the end of the week,
there will be some kind
of delivery to the client.
Because you deliver things as
you start to complete them,
or at least you deliver
semifinished versions
that look better and better.
And it's very important that
those deadlines must never,
ever, ever be late because
they are set in stone,
and you must deliver.
And so my wife's boss saw the
storm coming, so to speak,
and he knew that, maybe a year
and a half ago, two years ago,
he saw it coming that we
would get to the point
where we just didn't
have enough hardware
to make everyone happy.
And it would come that we would
have a Friday where we could
not actually deliver
what we had to deliver,
and we would just
disappoint the client
and be in a bad position.
And so he asked me,
a long time ago,
to work on a sort of
implementation that
would work together with
our current render farm
software in such a
way that is relatively
seamless for the artist,
because it just shows up
as another render note.
It's not its own separate thing.
It's not a whole other
completely isolated, brand
new system, per se.
It sort of comes as
part of the same network
as the current
farm, so it almost
gets treated as if it was
a neighbor, so to speak.
MARK MANDEL: And then what?
You're able to use that to
expand your capabilities
and sort of use that elastic
Cloud to grow as you need it?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah.
Once we had everything
configured more or less right,
you can very easily-- we were
using the managed instance
groups feature, and we
have a few common templates
for different specs,
and usually we
do different specs
for different shows
depending on how
much they require.
And we've been really-- we use a
lot of the dynamic-- the custom
instance, where you can drag
and drop the number of cores,
the number of amount of RAM.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
ALAN FREGTMAN: Ever
since that was an option,
we've been using it a lot.
And we always use
custom instances
because sometimes you don't
really need all that much RAM,
but we need more cores.
And I'm excited to
say that the Cloud
machines, that the top
of the Cloud machines,
are considerably better than
what we have on premise.
And it's an ongoing race.
I mean, the second
that we-- it's
very expensive to do a
massive upgrade of whatever,
200 notes that we have
locally, and get them
all to the latest specs.
And then within a few months,
there's something new.
And having the Cloud, being
able to burst so easily,
in a matter of seconds you can
launch hundreds of machines,
and it's so fast
and so effortless
that it's a great thing to
have just when you really
need to burst and
you need resources
to finish the computation
of producing those images.
We use a renderer called
Arnold, which was recently
acquired by Autodesk,
and we do most
of our work out of this
Maya and effects in Houdini,
and compositing in Nuke
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So as soon as you started
talking about rendering,
preemptible machines
came to mind.
Is this something that you use,
or have you consider using it?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yes.
We actually do use them.
We don't use them exclusively,
because at the moment,
it's up to the discretion
of the wrangler, which
is the person-- the human
being managing the farm
or overlooking the farm.
It's up to their
discretion how many
machines should
come up, depending
on what our resources are.
Like we only have so many.
We have a fair
number of licenses,
but we only have so many.
So sometimes we'll need a bit
more on local, then a bit more
on Cloud.
It all depends.
It fluctuates a lot,
and it's a hard task
to do programmatically.
So for now, we need
the human element
of a wrangler to make the call.
Now, that said, we
do have scripts.
Once the machines come
on and they become idle,
they start to die very quickly.
One of the great things
with the Google Cloud
is the per-minute billing.
I know there's a
10-minute minimum,
but after that, it's
per minute, and we
have a script that, after
the second idle minute,
the machine dies.
So we really try not to
waste any of the resources.
But to start them, at one
point we had given the artists
the ability to start
their own machines,
and they got a little crazy.
They would start a few
too many, and we quickly
realized that it had to
be overlooked by someone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm imagining
that at any point,
you have a decent amount of--
decent number of machines
running.
How do you make sure that they
all have a good configuration?
How do you manage
the software install
licenses and all that stuff?
ALAN FREGTMAN: So
just before-- I just
remembered one thing
about the preemptibles.
We do use them.
The thing is that we don't
use them exclusively,
because the way that they work
is they will die eventually
without notice.
But while the wrangler
is physically present
and at work, we will try to
use them as much as we can,
and then when they leave for
the night, we will do a switch,
and we'll start
some regular VMs.
And that way, we
know that there's
going to be some VMs left,
just to be totally sure.
MARK MANDEL: Is that
so if they happen
to shut down while
the person is looking,
they can manually restart them?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah,
basically that,
because they're more
likely to survive.
But during the day,
we use them as much
as we can when we use the Cloud.
And so to go to the next
question that you just asked,
we coordinate all the
configuration with SaltStack.
I don't know if you're
familiar with the technology.
MARK MANDEL: Can
you explain-- yeah,
explain for our
listeners, so for people
who aren't as familiar with it.
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah, it's a
configuration and deployment
tool.
The core is written in Python,
and I like Python so I like it.
It's quite configurable and
really, really flexible.
And it is very straightforward.
I mean, there's other
things like Ansible or Chef.
They're similar.
I haven't tried
many of the others,
but I really like Salt.
It's very easy to configure.
It's all based on YAML files,
which are very human readable.
You can have conditional
templating and multiple masters
if you want.
It's quite flexible.
And so we actually
use, for example--
we query some of the VM at
the data on the machine,
to configure itself.
So we set some tags and some--
well, not environment variable,
some metadata variables.
And we use those
to, for example,
configure which show that
the slave will be for.
And that's using Salt to read
the metadata to then configure
the machine on first boot.
MARK MANDEL: So like you're
talking about the person who's
working on the show, they
can fire up machines,
and they can then specify like
hey, I need these resources,
and then Salt will go off
and configure those resources
for them.
Does that sound about right?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah, basically
we use the managed instance
groups with the custom
templates that we
keep cloning a-- sort
of the default template.
We change a few attributes
for the specs and what show.
We have a code name for
each show, what code
name it will be for, and then
those machines will launch.
Given whatever number
you request of them,
they will appear,
and they will begin
taking jobs from the shows.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So you've been talking about
how you have an on prem and then
a Cloud shared solution.
How are you like-- I'm guessing
there are some assets that will
need to go like up and down.
How is that managed?
What sort of challenges
have you got there?
ALAN FREGTMAN:
Yeah, so initially
we tried stuff like
rsync and maybe even SCP,
which is not fast.
And it's very single threaded.
It works, but it's
really not fast.
And then I started
looking at options,
and there's a few that
are sort of flood via UDP
to maximize the throughput.
But the one that really
took the cake for me
was a piece of technology
from the guys at CERN,
the supercollider people.
They have a software called FDT.
It's very originally
called Fast Data Transfer,
and it's made in Java.
They don't provide the source.
It's not technically open
source, but it is free to use.
And it's incredibly fast.
You can use it over
a VPN SSH channel,
or directly if you want.
And basically it's
a bit like Aspera,
if you know what that is.
A lot of people use
it in my industry,
but Aspera is very expensive.
FDT is the same idea.
It's a a flood of UDP packets
that maximize your pipe,
and it's extremely concurrent.
You can start hundreds of
threads with a bunch of data,
and it all arrives
at the same time.
And it's so far the
only tool that we've
seen that can really
absolutely maximize our gigabit
pipe that we have
going to the internet.
MARK MANDEL: Are
you able to share
how fast you're able to
get some data transfers
or things you may have seen?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Well, we
only have a gigabit internet
at our studio at the moment,
and we pretty much fill it up.
We had like 800 to 900 megabits.
And we had a few times
when I was getting
started with this technology
that I accidentally
choked the network,
and for a few seconds
we lost internet because
it was too fast, which
I guess is a good problem to
have, better than too slow.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Now I'm also curious,
I guess you probably
work on some relatively big
budget and somewhat secret type
projects.
What do you have in
terms of security?
What sort of
considerations have you
had that way to make
sure everything is not
public to the
internet, probably,
in any way, shape, or form?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Yeah,
we try to-- well,
we use the Google
Cloud Platform firewall
to pretty much block all access,
except to the IP from Montreal.
That's one thing, and we try
to use VPN wherever possible.
And we believe that's
reasonably secure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
how are you using VPN?
Is that so the machines
that are on the Cloud
are able to access
the on-prem storage,
or do you use it for
some other things?
ALAN FREGTMAN: We
use it for licensing,
for licensing and to actually
talk to the farm software.
We use a software called Qube!
With a Q. It's from a
company called PipelineFX.
It's quite flexible.
We have used it
for many years now,
and we have customized it a lot.
And it's not rocket science.
It's basically a queue manager.
And people make jobs.
They give them attributes.
They give them what
cluster they should go for,
how much RAM they
should have, and so on.
And the machines
appear just the same
as the machines on the
local machines up here.
The Cloud ones are
just in the same place,
in the same interface,
the same everything.
So it's quite seamless.
The only thing is
that we require
having an upload
of the things that
are required by your scene file,
which is like one extra job.
And we require one
extra download job
so that the files,
as they complete,
they get downloaded back.
And we use FDT for that,
and it's very, very fast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What is the
process for someone to be like,
oh, we have this scene that
we need to process right now,
very fast.
Do you have a turbo
button or something?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Oh, I see.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: To start like a
bunch of instances or something
like that?
ALAN FREGTMAN: We do
not have a turbo button,
but we do, basically-- when
you submit a job to the Cloud,
it's the same as
submitting a job locally.
There's just a check box
that says use the Cloud.
And it just configures
the job differently.
It scans for the
dependencies of the thing
that you're rendering.
It tries to find all the
terabytes worth of textures,
and models, and
cameras, and animations,
and puts it in a big
upload job through FDT,
and then it submits to
the farm, just as it
would be without the Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're kind of
running out of time.
But is there anything
else that you'd
like to mention or something
that we had forgotten?
ALAN FREGTMAN: So
an interesting thing
I guess I'd like to
mention, is that we're
using Lustre FS for storage
solution in the Cloud.
It's an open source project
that allows very, very
easy distributed
redundant storage
across multiple machines.
In this case, we use VMs.
And it's a way to get
faster reads than just one
machine, one disk.
And it allows us to
scale really easily.
It's very easy to
add more-- they
call it bricks, more
sort of units of storage.
It's sort kind of like
adding more disks.
And it makes it very
easy and very fast,
and it's open source.
It takes like 10
minutes to get started
to do your first shared volume.
It's really quite wonderful.
And I had tried--
the very first time
that I started in the
Cloud, I tried to see
how fast could I get just
one machine with like an NFS
share that would be just
shared to a few machines.
And after something like 40
machines, it was just too much.
It just couldn't take it.
And that wasn't Google's
fault. It's just NFS is really
not the way to go.
One node cannot store
all your storage.
That's not going to scale.
But at the moment, we have
like six storage nodes,
and they're all sharing
several terabytes worth,
and it's very fast.
It's comparable to
what we have locally.
MARK MANDEL: Out
of curiosity, you
didn't use Google Cloud storage
because Lustre FS gives you
some other capability
or something?
Or what's the deal there?
ALAN FREGTMAN: Well, we didn't
use-- there's an open source
project to mount the
Google Cloud storage,
but it's not super
stable or super tested,
so I did not trust it
for serious production.
And Lustre just
allows us to have
a safe, redundant, shared
volume that something like NFS
would not be able to give us.
And we can't directly--
without mounting--
without having something to
mount a Google Cloud storage,
we can't directly use it.
So we use it as sort of
a transitionary place
or as a place for backups
and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: That's fine, cool.
Well, Alan, thank you
so much for joining us.
That was really interesting.
ALAN FREGTMAN: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: The world
of VFX is something
that I know nothing
about, and so it's
very interesting
to be able to see
behind the curtain a little bit.
ALAN FREGTMAN: Great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, very cool.
Thank you so much.
ALAN FREGTMAN: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So thanks
again to Alan for such
an interesting interview.
I know the next time I
will go to the movies,
I will be checking out is
this actually rendered?
Is this real?
It is pretty amazing what
they're able to do nowadays.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
There's definitely a few
movies that they've worked
on that now I want to go see.
So that's pretty cool as well.
Awesome.
So why don't we get stuck into
the question of the week, which
comes from the wonderful
community members
from the Google Cloud
Platform Slack Channel.
We were talking about-- on
there the other day about
say you have a Google Compute
Engine virtual machine,
and since you have
it up and running,
and you think to
yourself, oh, I'd
love to be able to scale this.
So what I want to
be able to do is
create an instance group, which
lets me scale that up and down
real easily.
Is there a way that I can
create a instance group
from an already running VM?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I actually had
to do this a long time ago
for a demo, which is actually
open source, and
we've talked about it
before, it's called Abelana.
And basically when I was in
the development phase of it,
I created an instance and then
installed ImageMagick on it.
And so ImageMagick was
actually a couple--
like it took me some time.
Then I realized that you could
do a pseudo sudo apt-get.
That's all.
Whatever.
But it took me some time to get
the whole environment working
correctly, and the
next step is like,
oh, OK, so now I want
to have this instance
but just running more of them.
And it is actually quite simple.
If you are in
development phase and you
can delete that instance,
it is pretty simple.
You can delete the instance
by making sure that you do not
delete the disk attached to it.
And then you can create a
new image from that disk.
And now when you create
your instance template
in the managed
instance group, you
can use that new image
that you just created.
So with that, you're good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's
not too many steps.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very simple.
So from your instance with the
disk, you delete the instance,
because to create
a new image, you
need a disk that is not
attached to anything.
So you first delete the instance
without deleting the disk,
then create an image, and
then from there, the template.
MARK MANDEL: So if we
have a VM that's running,
and you still want to be
able to work on it, though,
and you don't want to delete
it, what do we do then?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that is when
it becomes a little bit more
complicated.
Because basically
what you need to do
is an extra step
to generate a disk
that is not attached
to anything.
And to do that,
there's a little trick
that I did not
know about, but you
told me, which is create
a snapshot from the disk
and then a disk
from the snapshot.
And then the rest is the same.
MARK MANDEL: The
rest is the same.
So you can create
your image, you
can create your
instance template,
and you're good to go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which is--
it is actually pretty simple.
And that way, you are
able to go basically
from your prototype to
something that actually scales,
and you can do whatever
you want from it,
which is the normal
development process that I use.
The next step is normally,
oh, so now that everything
is already in
instances, maybe I will
use containers and move
to Container Engine,
and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: But
maybe you work on VMs.
That's where you're at,
and that's certainly cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And that
is totally fine, yep.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's great.
Awesome.
So thank you very much for
another episode, Francesc.
Are you going to be anywhere
exciting in the coming weeks?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So not really.
I'm actually going to
stay in San Francisco,
working on my videos and
working on a couple things
that I want to do.
MARK MANDEL: Do we
have some more episodes
of "Just for Funk" coming up?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I published one,
and there's a couple more
that I'm editing right now.
And if you have any
ideas about things
that you'd like to have on
that series, send them my way.
I'm always curious about it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
going to be kind
of attending a couple of
conferences coming up,
actually, which is just
a bit weird for me.
And that's kind of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
feels good, though,
when you go to a
conference, and you don't
have the pressure of speaking.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
I'll be at PAX Dev.
I'll be just attending
that, so hanging out
with a bunch of gamers, which
is something I love to do.
And then I'll be off to one
of my favorite conferences,
which is Strange Loop in
St. Louis in September.
There's some on session stuff.
I may end up doing a little
bit of something there.
We'll see how that goes.
But I'll definitely be there.
That's not an event
I would miss out on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So we have not
done it in a while,
so maybe we should
remind our listeners
how to get in touch with us.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So there's
a bunch of ways to do it.
We have a web page.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's gcppodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or?
MARK MANDEL:
Cloud.google.com/podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good.
Also, we have an email.
MARK MANDEL: Hello@gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We are on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: @gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Google+.
MARK MANDEL: @plusgcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: At /r/gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
finally, we are also,
we have the channel podcast
on the Google Cloud Platform
community Slack channel.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's a mouthful.
MARK MANDEL: It is a little.
All right, well, yes, thank you
so much again for joining me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you, and thank you
to our listeners
for being there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
talk to you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]